planet is home to 130,000 residents and
between us we produce many tons of
household waste every year some of which
is recycled already but we want to
increase our percentage from November
2013 we intend to improve our recycling
rates and we're working on a project
with the East Cape partnership to meet
our County commitments to recycling well
it's clearly better if we can recycle
our waste and working with residents
we'd like to improve our percentages
that we we do recycle and send less to
landfill our aim is to improve our
targets at the moment we recycle 26% and
we'd like to take that into at least the
containers and a Welcome Packet going
out to residents in October so let's
sort it out together
and make phone it an even better place
than it is already
introducing improved recycling for
Thanet coming November 2013 more ways to
recycle containers for more collections
let's sort it out together
and increase Nana to recycling 12 a 50%
mixed Drive recycling goes in the blue
lid we limit no blue box aerosol cans
jars and glass bottles plastic tubs
bottles pots and trays tins and cans and
tetrapack paper and card goes into the
red bag cereal boxes paper bags junk
mail newspapers cardboard envelopes
catalogs and magazines
food waste goes into the ground lockable
bin and silver kitchen caddy meat fish
and bones fruit and vegetables dairy
bread pasta and rice tea bags and coffee
grounds and eggshells all non recyclable
waste goes into the black we live in
poor black sack in your seagull proof
bag nappies plastic film and polystyrene
and bed waste garden waste goes into the
green lidded we live in hedge cuttings
flower cuttings plants grass cuttings
leaves twigs and small branches there is
an annual fee for the collection of
garden waste find out more online or
give us a call let's sort it out
together